moi je voudrais bien rencontrer
l'ingénieur qui a eu l'idée est géniale
décret des pistes cyclables à paris les
fameuses bandelettes j'aurai des mois
lui dire parce que c'est rudement bien
pensé les banques bnp côté trottoir
vous avez les couloirs réservés aux
autobus et aux taxis aux milliers vous
avez les autos entrée l'aider les vélos
ip plis s'échapper tôt ou tard les
cyclistes ou les coince il est pris en
sandwich
il est petit alors messieurs les
écologistes ne comptez pas sur moi pour
vous suivre ces voix là les vélos oui
les pièges à cons non voilà
croyez-moi pierre paris ils voient bien
roulé en auto et je voudrais bien
pouvoir mais stationné quelques épreuves
regardez-moi ça n'y a pas une place
peuvent pas aller stationnée dans un
parking non wololo mise et y prend un
préfet risquaient une contravention
ah ben voilà il remercie au passage
clouté pompiers n'ont pas besoin des
trois mètres pour traverser les piétons
et donc à passer un deal en jean ou la
la qu'est ce qui fait sourire ou ses
lilas commun des pailles et vous écrasez
vient alors vous voyez pas clé mais plus
c'est pas un trottoir en commun c'est un
passage clouté et bassiste et bon marché
sur les clous pas si ma voisine
non mais vous avez vu cette arrogance
j'aurais piles écrasés comme une
business
et au lieu des cinq et l'histoire de la
vie il en profite pour manger les
saletés des piétons bas non mais sans
blague pas des sauvages sont maintenant
pas me laisser monter sur les pieds
moines ont défié permet pas inquiet
quand vous sortez de chez vous lui amène
au volant parce que j'avais déjà des
fois qu'on essaie de l'approcher
ça y est voilà une aubergine et à 500
voitures en stationnement
vous allez voir que c'est la mienne qui
l'intéressent et bonjour madame
l'aubergine aiment la plage en commun il
faut pas rester là-bas non moi je reste
pas là c'est seulement ma voiture
moi je les communs c'est pas une raison
pour stationner sur les clous et mais
c'est ce que j'aime et il lui dit mais
il était petit c'est dj bakhat indymac
j'ai pour lui dire j'y vas pas là elle y
va quand même
ça y est les autres en chantier
ma femme c'est pareil pour un oui pour
un non elles sont toujours intrigué et
c'est moi qui paye savez qui vous
ressemble et alice sapritch vous est pas
lisse à bridge et comprend toujours les
vtt cathérine d'élèves a en voilà déjà
dit vous voyez que je baratine pas un
mais si je peux me permettre un petit
conseil vous avez des jo lisier c'est
dommage qu'il ait caché pas des grosses
lunettes
pourquoi vous mettez pas plus tôt à la
place et vous savez des petits pois et
des lentilles oui vous êtes gentils
jeunes épaules milite elle est charmante
avec les paniers toujours moyen de
s'entendre se voir réclamer n ya rien à
faire c'est une santé bon je voudrais
bien pouvoir traverser moi vous me
laissez passer ou non il ya des morceaux
y en a pas et qui va s'arrêter je me
demande à quoi ça sert des maîtres des
passages caoutchouté réservé aux piétons
personne ne les respecte on nous chasse
comme des canards sauvages
bon alors je suis non officiel encore là
demain au logis mais 100% n'arriverait
jamais vivant de votre côté comment
madame qui je vous prennent les bras
pourquoi fait on ne se connaît pas
et ben ont traversé mais je n'arrive
déjà pas à traverser moi même vous voyez
vous m j'suis pas un porte-bagages
bon allez montez et aurait des membres à
vous mêler rendrait dès votre côté
allons-y
alors chacun pour soi et dieu pour moi
la vie
or les saletés des mets des mes cd va
encore un allemand il y est gisquet
donnery d'écraser nos fils et nos
compagnes
comment baissier pour aller aux
invalides et ben vous traversez il vous
coupe les pattes et vous y êtes aux
invalides